i stand by all of the evidence i gave to
the committee
nicola sturgeon rubbished the
revelations on thursday
on friday her defense rested but on a
day when the first minister laid low
colleagues laid in to the committee that
said
she misled parliament should the first
minister
resign after being found to have misled
parliament
and if she so instantly and quickly
dismisses that finding by the
harassment committee what was the point
of the inquiry in the first place
i do not believe the first minister
should resign i do not believe she has
misled parliament
and i have absolute confidence in her
veracity of what she said in those eight
hours
of evidence to that committee in her
integrity and in her professionalism
the scottish conservatives called for a
resignation by tuesday
otherwise they'd pursue a no-confidence
vote on wednesday
labour's uk leader on a visit north
stayed south of a resignation call
for now it's about the integrity of the
scottish parliament
it's about the integrity of the office
of first minister and public
and standard in public life
scots waking up to news their first
minister was judged to have misled
parliament
also learned the hollywood committee had
other concerns
the committee concluded it found it hard
to believe
that nicola sturgeon didn't have any
concerns about inappropriate behavior by
alex salmond
before november 2017.
it said that if she did have such
knowledge she should have acted upon it
and if she had that knowledge she's
misled the committee
that's not a finding they made it's a
concern they had
all this just weeks short of an election
keenly contested
in marginal seats like edinburgh central
she has been keeping truths
and half truths from the public
and quite frank and quite frankly
i think that's unacceptable i don't
think the first minister has
misled parliament as i say i think a lot
of the conclusions from this report are
largely down to political partisanship
a separate independent investigation
will be published next week
on whether nikola sturgeon broke the
ministerial code more fallout from the
salmon sturgeon affair
is a certainty the uncertainty is just
how far it falls
james matthews sky news edinburgh